in the last video we set out to figure
out the surface area of the walls of
this weird-looking building where the
ceiling of the walls was defined by the
function f of X Y is equal to X plus y
squared and then the base of this
building or the the contour of its walls
was defined by the path where we have a
circle of radius 2 along here then we go
down along the y axis and then we take
another left and we go along the x axis
and that was our building and in the
last video we figured out this first
walls surface here in fact you can think
of it our original problem is we wanted
to figure out the line integral along
the closed path so it was a closed line
integral along the closed path C of f of
X Y of f of X Y and where every oh and
we're always multiplying f of XY times a
little bit a little small distance of
our path D s we're writing this in the
most abstract way possible and what we
saw in the last video is the easiest way
to do this is to break this up into
multiple paths or into multiple problems
so you can imagine this whole contour
this whole path we call C but we could
call this part that we figured out in
the last video c1 this part we can call
let me make a pointer c2 and then this
point right here is c3 so we could
redefine or we can break up this line
integral this closed line integral into
three non closed line angles this will
be equal to the line integral along the
path c1 of f of XY DS plus the line
integral along c2 of F of XY f of XY d s
plus the line integral and you might
have guessed it along c3 of F of XY D s
and in the in the last video we got as
far as figuring out this first part this
first curvy wall right here it's the
surface area we figured out was 4 plus 2
pi 4 plus 2 pi now we got to figure out
the other two parts so let's do C 2
let's do this line integral next and in
order to do it we need to do another
parametrizations and why it's going to
be different than what we did for this
part we're no longer
along this circle we're just along the
y-axis so as long as we're there X is
definitely going to be equal to zero so
that's my parametrizations X is equal to
zero for along the y-axis X is
definitely equal to zero and then Y we
could say it starts off at Y is equal to
two Y is equal to two maybe we'll say Y
is equal to two minus T for T is between
zero T is greater than or equal to zero
less than or equal to two and that
should work when T is equal to zero
we're at this point right there and then
as T increases towards two we move down
the y-axis until eventually when T is
equal to two we're at that point right
there so that's our parametrizations and
so let's evaluate this line in actually
we could do our derivatives two if we
like what's the derivative let's limit
right here what's DX DT pretty
straightforward derivative 0 0 and dy DT
is equal to is equal to the derivative
of this is just minus 1 right 2 minus T
derivative of minus T is just minus 1
and so let's just break it up so we have
this thing right here so we have the
integral along c2 but let's instead of
writing c2 well I'll leave c2 there but
we'll say we're going from T is equal to
0 to 2 of f of XY f of XY so f of XY is
this thing right here is X plus y
squared and then times D s times D s and
we know from the last several videos D s
can be re-written as the square root of
DX DT squared so 0 squared plus dy DT
squared so minus 1 squared is 1 all of
that times DT and obviously this is
pretty nice it clean gets very nice and
clean this is 0 plus 1 square root this
just becomes 1 and then what is X X if
we write it in terms of our
parameterization is always going to be
equal to 0 and then Y squared is going
to be 2 minus T squared so this is going
to be 2 minus T squared so this whole
crazy thing
five - we're going to go from T is equal
to 0 to t is equal to 2 the X disappears
in our parametrizations X just stays
zero regardless of what T is of what and
then you have Y squared but Y is the
same thing as 2 minus T so 2 minus T
squared and then you have your DT
sitting out there this is pretty
straightforward I always find it easier
I always find it easier to find when
you're finding an antiderivative of this
although you can do this in your head I
like to just actually multiply out this
binomial so this is going to be equal to
the antiderivative from T is equal to 0
to T is equal to 2 of 4 minus 2 minus 4t
plus T squared plus T squared just like
that DT and then this is pretty
straightforward this is going to be the
antiderivative of this is for t minus 2t
squared right when you take the
derivative two times minus 2 is minus 4t
and then you have plus plus 1/3 T to the
third right these are just simple anti
derivatives and we need to evaluate it
from 0 to 2 and so let's evaluate it at
2 4 times 2 is 8 let me just pick a new
color 4 times 2 is 8 minus 2 times 2
squared so 2 times 4 so minus 8 plus 1/3
times 2 to the third power so 1/3 times
8 so these cancel out we have 8 minus 8
and we just have 8/3 so this just
becomes 8/3 and then we have to put a 0
in minus zero evaluated here but it's
just going to be 0 we have 4 times 0 2
times 0 all of these going to be 0 so
minus 0 so just like that we found our
surface area of our second wall of our
second wall this turned out being this
right here is 8/3 and now we have our
last wall and then we could just add
them up so we have our last wall we're
looking so
just I'll do another parameterization I
want to have the graph there well maybe
I can paste it again edit so there's the
graph again and now we're going to do
our last wall so our last wall is this
one right here which is we could write
it you know this was c3 let me switch
colors here so this is C we're going to
go along contour c3 of f of X Y D s
which is the same thing as let's do a
parametrizations
along this curve if we just say X is
equal to T very straightforward for T is
greater than or equal to 0 less than or
equal to 2 and then this whole time that
we're along the x axis Y is going to be
equal to 0 that's pretty straightforward
parametrizations so this is going to be
equal to we're going to go from T is
equal to 0 to T is equal to 2 T is equal
to 2 of f of X Y which is I'll write in
terms of X right now X&Y X plus y
squared times D s now what is DX well
let me write D's right here times DX
that's what we're dealing with
now we know what D s is d s is equal to
the square root of DX DT squared plus dy
DT squared times DT we proved that in
the first video or we didn't rigorously
prove it but we got the sense of why
this is true and what's the derivative
of X with respect to T well that's just
1 so this is just going to be a 1 1
squared same thing and derivative of Y
with respect to T is 0 so this is 0 1
plus 0 is 1 square root of 1 is 1 so
this thing just becomes this thing just
becomes DT DT D s is going to be equal
to DT in this case so this just becomes
a DT and then our X is going to be equal
to a T that's part our definition of our
parametrizations and y is 0 so we can
ignore it so this was a super simple
integral so this simplified down to
we're going to go from 0 to 2 of T DT
which is equal to the antiderivative T
is
1/2 T squared and we're going to go zero
to two which is equal to 1/2 times 2
squared 2 squared is 4 times 1/2 is 2
and then minus 1/2 times 0 squared minus
0 so the this third walls area right
there is just two pretty pretty
straightforward so that right there the
area there is just 2 and so to answer
our question what was this line integral
evaluated over this closed path of f of
X Y well we just add up these numbers we
have 4 plus 2 pi plus 8/3 plus 2 well
what is this 8/3 is the same thing as 2
and 2/3 so we have 4 plus 2 and 2/3 is 6
and 2/3 plus another 2 is 8 and 2/3 so
this whole thing becomes 8 and 2/3 if
you write it as a mixed numbers plus 2
pi and we're done and we're done now we
can start trying to do line integrals
with vector valued functions